this is
our apartment in beirut
[Music]
these used to be balcony doors
they are completely blown off
this is some of my daughter's toys and
books
when the blast hit i'm standing here in
the apartments about here
when the blast hit i was uh
taking my daughter to the bathroom came
out to call my
colleagues and see if we could figure
out what happened
and uh my daughter came out
from the doorway here behind us
she said daddy what was that and i
turned
uh and uh
the blast hit me from behind
i was standing uh looking to the back
here
you can see the windows behind me and
the blast came from behind
i threw myself on top of her threw
myself on top of her on the ground
the blast engulfed us
wood glass debris
unlike any other blast anything i've
ever experienced
i don't know how we survived especially
after seeing what happened to my
neighbor
so i was going to close the balcony
so as i was closing the balcony
uh it blew in my face i saw the white
smoke he did
and uh it threw me like five
five meters six meters all the way
across the living room
oh my gosh
this is what beirut looks like
in this neighborhood
blocks and blocks of shattered cars
this is basically right across
from the blast site this is the
epicenter of the block these buildings
we took the full grunt of the shockwaves
that decimated the city
this is the recovery work going on here
this
is the wall street journal office in
beirut on the top floor there
it's the first time i'm seeing it
actually windows are blown out
this is just kind of the culmination of
frustration that so many people have
with
this country we moved here last
september right before
anti-government protests swept this
nation that people
thought uh might be the beginning of
some new change
that was followed by the coronavirus
pandemic and
a shutdown people followed kept it in
check for a while but
led to economic devastation and then the
economic collapse here the currency
collapsed
massive hyperinflation on the scale of
venezuela swept the country
power outages here up to 22 hours a day
and now this
you